olivier delorme bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin en direct sur rt
france alors on le disait depuis
quelques jours le président turc affiche
clairement sa volonté de renouer avec
l'europe vous voyez ce qu'il disait la
semaine dernière faire de 2021 une année
de succès pour les relations entre
l'union européenne et la turquie est à
notre portée nous pouvons y arriver en
travaillant avec une vision à long terme
loin des préjugés des appréhensions
l'incertitude créée par le brr exit
pourrait être surmontées si la turquie
prend la place qu'elle mérite au sein de
la famille de l'union européenne alors
comment comprendre cette volte face ces
derniers jours c'est quoi c'est
prévisible après les sanctions a mis en
place en décembre par l'union européenne
ou alors est-ce que c'est autre chose on
écoute et c'est purement tactique le
président erdogan est coutumier de ce
genre de revirements il alterne le chaud
et le froid les coups de force et les
caresses et comme il sait qu'il a en
face de lui une union européenne qui est
très divisé et et qui n'a pas de volonté
en réalité parce que l'allemagne a une
position outrageusement pro turc e suivi
par malte l'italie et l'espagne et la
hongrie
et donc qu'ils essayent d'enfoncer le
coin entre la grèce et ses alliés de
plus en plus nombreux dans l'union
européenne qui voit bien que ce régime
est un régime à la fois qu'ils nient les
libertés publiques et politiques à
l'intérieur qui est en grande difficulté
à l'intérieur en raison de de son
incompétence économique et de sa gestion
désastreuse de la crise du covin et puis
les manipulations des des communautés
turques en europe occidentale
voilà donc ils essayent de ils essayent
de reprendre la main avant l'arrivée de
bail donne au pouvoir six éléments
justement est ce que en se rapprochant
de l'union européenne aurait tout à y
perdre oad envoie aussi un message à la
future administration maiden oui oui
tout à fait il ya une tentative il y à
une tentative de jouer l'europe contre
les états unis
il est il est clair si vous voulez que
dans les derniers mois de
l'administration trump l'administration
trump âme et notamment mike pompéo a
marqué une grande un grand énervement
vis-à-vis de l'imprévisibilité du régime
turc
les etats-unis ont le congrès des
etats-unis a adopté des sanctions fortes
bien plus forte que les ridicules
sanctions européennes et est donc
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les démocrates qui arrivent
au pouvoir semble avoir une position
beaucoup plus dure encore que trump et
son administration dans les derniers
temps et donc erdogan se fait du souci
il faut voir notamment que la livre
turque n'en finit pas de n'en finit pas
de perdre de la valeur elle a perdu 30%
au moins deux ans dans l'année 2020
alors elle a rebondi en fin d'année
parce que le qatar est venue au secours
financier de qui est un des derniers
alliés fiables d'erdogan est venue au
secours d'erdogan en mettant beaucoup
d'argent sur la table mais depuis
quelques jours la glissade de la livre
turque recommence et donc erdogan est
dans une position extrêmement
extrêmement délicate
il essaye en bon politique de tirer
parti des divisions européennes et il
craint beaucoup plus donc vous ne lisiez
joe biden que donald trump pourquoi
alors ne pas écouter parce que les think
tanks les les cercles de réflexion
démocrates semblent avoir recommandé à
la nouvelle administration des positions
beaucoup plus dure vis-à-vis de la
turquie qui en réalité est devenu un est
devenu un élément déstabilisateur en
méditerranée orientale
elle remet en cause elle remet en cause
le droit international maritime dans
toute la méditerranée orientale et
notamment et elle est en effet en très
mauvais termes avec deux alliés
fondamentaux des états unis l'egypte et
israël qui avec lesquelles la grèce qui
est au premier rang avec chypre de la
menace turque face à la menace turque où
nous et grâce au ministre des affaires
étrangères grec des des liens des
alliances régionales qui vise à contenir
cette menace turque
et puis il faut ajouter l'achat de
rachat par la turquie de données cs300
russe qui ne passe pas aux états unis et
est qui qui sont une mesure qui est pris
comme quelque chose d'une de l'ordre de
la trahison alors l'administration trump
avait déjà exclu la turquie du programme
d'avions f-35 mais probablement on va
voir aujourd'hui on va voir aujourd'hui
une accentuation de cette politique et
notamment une continuation il va falloir
voir mais une continuation de
de la diminution des activités de la
base de la base
autant dinsi reliques qui était
autrefois une base absolument
fondamental du dispositif américain
or c'est les activités de cette base
sont en train de se replier
depuis maintenant plusieurs années mais
probablement ça va s'accélérer vers vers
la base crétoise de soude à evere
alexandroupolis le test sera de savoir
si les américains vont enlever dinsi
reliques les armes atomiques qui sont
qui sont entreposés jusqu'ici merci
beaucoup olivier delorme d'avoir partagé
votre expertise sur notre antenne je
rappelle que cet historien auteur de la
grèce et les balkans